[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avoir des enfants
je crois que nounours vous a préparé une
surprise
appelez-moi chef pas trop ce soir je
suis de grands chefs de cuisine lourtier
tu as même apporté ton livre de recettes
prépare nous de bons plats grands chefs
nous sommes impatients d'apprécier les
talents culinaires
ce sont des recettes extraordinaires
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
les europe où le cheval gros pot au feu
il va être drôlement content annonces
vont faire mieux parce que j'ai beau
soir mes petits marmitons des marmitons
ce sont les aides du grand cuisinier
grands cuisiniers cosina hispano là où
la tortilla de patatas macaronis
patatras 6-2 jeudi pas là
mousse bien c'est un des pâles en ce que
ça va être bon je n'y a que j'aime est
logique que si d'espagnac
attendez vous m'en direz des nouvelles
au travail c'est un des prélats
assiettée vous notre matin un polio
atroce 1 kg de langoustines as une
pimento repos un ko arros une poko de
safran moi non plus une peau de safran
qu'est ce que ça veut dire non du
courage vous allez voir comment un grand
chef invente la cuisine espagnole une
grande casserole
[Musique]
miguel les spaghettis aux gueules nougat
moon goguen una tabata pour le jus
budget
des poivrons pour la couleur ou guen du
sel l'art au homebrew à 9
olé wignehies et pour finir à ross
tuerie faut pas mélanger ne rien avec
les spaghetti avec du seul
ça se pourrait pourquoi pas eh bien nous
on mangera pas sûr que je vais goûter et
vous n'en aurez pas là parce que j'ai
tout seul
bonne nuit prochaine elle est très bonne
va près là ils ne m'ont même pas laissé
le temps de la faire cuire à la patron
jamie chaque fois c'est la même chose
pas moyen de faire proprement son
travail
[Musique]
allez vite vous coucher des enfants
mais lorsque vous voudrez faire de la
cuisine et préparer de bons petits plats
demandez plutôt conseil à votre maman
alors grand chef j'ai compris nounours
tu es vexé je suis le mieux
patron
on y va en route
tu seras mieux la prochaine fois à
nounours
la nuit des enfants rois deux tours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]